hi I'm in right and this is what it
takes to support Bible
[Music]
there we go me and my brother Morris I
just wanted to be Morris really cuz he
was a good footballer and this this
brings me back to just just do
everything what he was doing when he's
playing football
Muricy was so he was just like such a an
influence on me teased me for the whole
of my life all I remember him teasing me
and in it inadvertently made me a better
player because I just practiced
everything using cocking your left foot
you can't head you're not as quick as me
you can't dribble like me and so this
history but this brings me straight back
to all those times of the tease in what
he used to do it's a great pitch I love
it so I had a few pictures of thing I've
got with is my mum as well to be honest
but well mom didn't shape me as a as a
person on football I'd you know it was
it was quite her I can say it was it was
a tough tough household there wasn't a
lot of loving and hugging down on so you
know I mean there was a lot of stuff
that my mom used to say about not being
able to make it and many a call and for
your chosen but you know at the time I
wasn't paying much attention you know so
it was a it was a fractious kind of
relationship and football got me through
those times
everything about that the being in the
house and you know the pressure in the
house the the relief and the release
from it was was football not as
perseverance and I don't really didn't
that didn't come in yet when I first
went to to have trials in 1112 I was I
don't know maybe
overconfident and then you go down you
feel you have to play a certain way
because you can't lose the ball in
certain places so I think I went to all
the trials you know I was trying to play
a game that wasn't very natural to me
I was very safe and you know trying to
hold a ball and try to link play wasn't
done I've got the ball take people on
try things something I thought I had to
do in trials and I never got into any I
think I wasn't being true to myself and
all that plane when I was younger
dribbling around people scoring goals
seen how long you could keep the ball
for that's
was about I needed to integrate that
we've yeah part into people when it was
on to pass to them and that's why I say
to people from the age of eight to
twelve and remember falls into it he
woke up he had a teacher that intervened
well I was mr. pignon he was a major
influence on my life from the age of
seven you know he was the first real
male figure in my life who showed me a
lot of love and attention and care he
really did care for me he helped me with
my my my reading right in which I was
struggling with when I was like seven
and they didn't had a problem in
respects of the paying attention and he
used to use these are the times here
used to use football as if you don't do
this properly and if darling you will
not be able to play on Saturday and that
would focus my mind he gave me a kind of
fatherly figure teacher mentor kind of
care that I needed at that time I always
feel like I'm the best player ever
when I finished speaking to mr. pignon
he gave me that me playing for England
was the proudest moment of ease of his
life because all he wanted to do is
teach and I ended up being that that
that pupil that made it worth my while
for him I don't know how do you explain
that to somebody that is magnificent for
me and I'm delighted round absolutely
delight ran and he was a major major
influence in my life I'd say the most
important influence on my life was mr.
people this is an unbelievable picture
this is the coming off the bench for a
palace this is the second goal from
enough at Wembley 1990
mr. one is this it was touching the
rainbow black mr. pignon said look for
the big part of the goal and it was
there to his right all I saw was
stimulating coming and it was a lot of
gold so I just done it all just happen
Bam Bam Bam Bam this is a this is like a
personal accolade in respect of my
massive career which is I'd say yeah
that the greatest day of my life this
one was
broke a record when I went to answer
there with champions the last two times
that last three years so there's a
dressing room of Champions I went into
and I just wanted to go there and prove
that I was good enough belief belief and
faith in yourself you know firstly for
David Dean and George Graham to pay two
and a half million pounds for you at the
time she's a lot of money you know that
kind of gives you a belief that somebody
has got enough faith in you to make that
outlay
then you've got to have the faith in
yourself and your ability to be able to
deliver when I joined Pallas and Steve
Coppell said to me never change your
approach to the way you play football I
was true to myself and how I played
that's what Arsenal bought and I think
that's what I deliver to him
perseverance you know there's not many
words that um when I think back that's
the first one that comes my perseverance
and faith you have to be able to look at
yourself in the mirror and and believe
what you see I'm just looking and saying
I believe that I was better than people
I saw that I was better than people that
were getting further in these when I was
younger and the mere fact I loved the
game so much is why I didn't stop it
played football Sunday morning football
and I persevered I had faith in myself
people can criticize nothing wrong with
that it's their opinion people's opinion
you can't accept someone's opinion
simply because they say that they don't
think you're good enough I had that for
many many many years and you know what I
mean
I don't need to go to those people so
see how harsh I here I am pretty wrong
the fact is is that you're doing it
you're living it minute by minute the
other one who has to pick yourself up
you're the one who's living it every day
you don't want to look yourself in the
mirror and you have to continue to
persevere if that is what you want
that's the main thing and that's what I
wanted now wanting it I wanted it really
badly and I persevered and there was
nothing I wasn't prepared to do in
respect of training and working on
myself to get it so perseverance I do
believe that women's football is on a
massive upward curve I'm very very
excited about what is going on with the
women's game at a minute
the best way that I can help is my
platform every school by the year 2020
for young girls will have the
opportunity to play football
and I want to make sure that if my girls
in nine and seven want that then it's
there for them so that is what I want to
do that is my role in it it's a role
that I'm very excited about hi
I'm in right and this is what it takes
you